>> John Fenn: Hello!
I'm John Fenn at the American
Folklife Center, and I'm here
with musician, percussionist,
composer Jaimeo Brown.
>> Jaimeo Brown: Yes.
>> John Fenn: We're going
to talk a little bit
about the way you've been
incorporating field recordings
into the kind of work
you've been doing,
stuff you've been
finding in our archives.
>> Jaimeo Brown: Yes.
>> John Fenn: But first,
I want to hear kind
of brief background
of yours in music.
How did you get into
what you're doing?
>> Jaimeo Brown: Yes.
I was blessed to come
from a musical family.
Mother and father both musicians
and educators and did a lot
of work for the Endowment
for the Arts.
My father, Dartanyan Brown,
my mother, Marcia Miget,
did a lot of traveling in
the '80s with the Endowment
for the Arts, and I was carrying
equipment while they were
traveling to different
colleges teaching
about music and music education.
And I kind of resisted
it as a result
of the parent factor
there until later on.
And around 16 years old I --
-- discovered the drums, or
maybe the drums discovered me.
>> John Fenn: Mm-hmm.
>> Jaimeo Brown: And
I eventually was now
in the position to
have to catch up.
So after really looking at
musicians like John Coltrane
and some of these who
were my initial heroes,
I started to practice eight
hours a day on the drums
and eventually moved out from
California to New York City.
Went to William Paterson
University.
It was headed by Rufus
Reid at the time,
incredible bass player
and educator.
In that period of time, that
was the real education of being
in the streets of New York
performing and just being
around that artistic
scene in New York.
And being of the generation
where I was really, you know,
trained to be a musician,
following these traditions
of jazz and music that was
a bit older, of course.
My generation was also
a generation of hip hop
and electronic music
and sampled music.
And so it was always a very
natural fit of being able
to merge music that was very
organic and acoustic with music
that was more digital.
And so a lot of the music that
I heard, the hip hop artists
like J Dilla and some of these
producers really just became
extensions of being able to
create what I was hearing.
And so I eventually discovered
an incredible group called the
Gee's Bend Group.
And they are a group,
or a community really,
so more in Gee's Bend, Alabama.
And this led me on a long path
of really getting into finding,
discovering some of
the oldest sources
of African American music in the
country and eventually went back
to Rutgers University
to get my masters.
My thesis was on
how the earliest,
some of the early
music of the church,
the Black church
influenced jazz, rock,
contemporary music, so to speak.
And as that journey began,
I wanted to hear more
of what the earliest music
sounded like, not just the,
not just conceptually
from reading,
but actually hearing it.
And so that led me to, of
course, the Library of Congress,
which of course, led me
to works with Alan Lomax
and so many other historians
who gave me the opportunity
to actually really be able
to hear the sound quality,
which is going to change
through generations.
There's certain sounds in --
-- in the voicing, the
characteristics of the voice
that you just don't
hear anymore.
So that led me to
the processing.
I really need to, I really
need to capture this sound.
So I started to figure
out how could I take some
of these samples
and include them
into composition
and into production.
And so this archive here
has been a huge source
of inspiration and a huge source
of information and history
that has informed
what Transcendence is,
which is my group that really
focuses on bringing art,
history, and technology
together.
And so this archive
being here and being able
to perform here tonight,
it's just a,
it's a big circle completing
and it's just a great, great,
great honor to be here.
>> John Fenn: Well, it's
interesting hearing you talk
about this sort of, the
elements of the sound
because there's a certain
texture in field records.
>> Jaimeo Brown: Mm, yes.
>> John Fenn: And
we'll get to the ones
that you sort of hit on.
>> Jaimeo Brown: Yes.
>> John Fenn: But I was just
wondering to what extent,
as you're going through
this trove
of historical recordings and --
>> Jaimeo Brown: Yes.
>> -- in our archives
or elsewhere too.
>> Jaimeo Brown: Yes.
>> John Fenn: What's catching
your ear as a composer,
as a percussionist,
as someone that grew
up with hip hop and jazz?
>> Jaimeo Brown: Hmm, yes.
Yes.
>> John Fenn: You
know, what's --
>> Jaimeo Brown: Yeah.
>> John Fenn: There's some
of that spirituality in some
of that stuff, but it's like --
>> Jaimeo Brown:
They're, the, you know,
we live in a digital age now,
and everything is
becoming more micro.
But when you, when I'm going,
you know, when I was going
through reel to reel --
>> John Fenn: Mm-hmm.
>> Jaimeo Brown: -- and hearing
not just the sound of the voices
but the sound of the actual
first recording instruments
that were used.
>> John Fenn: Mm-hmm.
>> Jaimeo Brown: It's going
to give a certain character
to the music that I
think is very important,
especially when I'm thinking
about balancing those
two worlds together.
>> John Fenn: Mm-hmm.
>> Jaimeo Brown: And so those
voices and the sound of the,
the times coming through,
through the accents and,
and you know, just to be able to
actually hear time in this age.
We're only 100 years now where
we're actually able to record --
>> John Fenn: Mm-hmm.
>> Jaimeo Brown:
-- these things.
I think these things
just come out so loudly
and just give me
ideas for balancing.
You know, a lot, oftentimes
I'm trying to balance that idea
of future and what is
ancient and what is future.
And some of those sounds
really, really capture that,
that almost ancient
sound in a sense,
being the oldest recordings
that we actually have.
>> John Fenn: And
that element of time
and history is interesting,
too, when you think of when,
something you just said, like
what, Lomax was recording
on instaneous disks, right?
>> Jaimeo Brown: Yes.
>> John Fenn: So those recorded
in the moment, not
easy to copy --
>> Jaimeo Brown: Yup, yup.
>> John Fenn: -- when
we copy them to tape --
>> Jaimeo Brown: Yeah, yup.
>> John Fenn: -- you
know, which is what,
how you might acces them then --
>> Jaimeo Brown: Yup, yup.
>> John Fenn: -- if
they've not been digitized.
>> Jaimeo Brown: Yes.
>> John Fenn: So
there's kind of a theme
of time and texture that's --
>> Jaimeo Brown: Definitely.
>> John Fenn: -- working in
what you're doing with this.
>> Jaimeo Brown: One
hundred percent, 100%.
I think that's, that's
I think, largely what,
in this also generation I
think helps balance the speed
of technology and how
fast that it's moving.
And because of that exponential
growth of technology,
I think that there is part
of me that was really drawn
to that actual quality,
you know.
There's just real work put into
some of the early recordings
and how they were actually
recorded in the first place
and physically how it was done.
And all of that definitely
comes through in the music.
>> John Fenn: And you know,
yeah, I mean just thinking
about some of the
songs that you're,
some of the field
recordings you're dealing
with that you're turning
into compositions,
a few of them are work wongs.
>> Jaimeo Brown: Yeah, yes.
Yes.
>> John Fenn: And so can
you speak a little bit
about what you are hearing when
you're hearing these work songs?
>> Jaimeo Brown: Sure.
Yeah.
Some of these, some of
these work songs were sung.
The Parchman Farm is
a prison in Alabama,
so you're hearing actual
inmates singing work songs
that they would sing doing
extremely hard manual labor.
And so automatically
you're going
to get extremely vivid strong
images from this type of,
from the sound of people who
weren't necessarily musicians.
>> John Fenn: Mm-hmm.
>> Jaimeo Brown: You know,
these are regular people
who used the music as, almost
as a form of transcendance
and transcending the
difficulty of life.
And so when you're able to
hear music used in that form,
to me it's extremely refreshing
because a lot of the music
that we hear nowadays and the
way that our culture functions,
music is often used more
functionally as something just
for strictly performance.
And so within listening
to these old recordings
that these prison inmates
singing while they're chopping
wood or while they're --
-- or railroad, or
hitting railroads
or picking cotton or --
-- or farming for 12 hours a day
and hearing how music was used
is very, very powerful for me.
And it definitely even
has inspired a lot
of ideas and compositions.
And also within this idea, too,
we're also exploring, for me,
the African American experience
and how slavery evolved as well,
you know, because the prison
system at one time took
over for slavery and at a
point there's so much --
-- so much upheaval
during that time.
And to be able to hear the
sounds of that time is going
to have very, once
again, loud images just
by hearing some of these voices.
>> John Fenn: What's
the research process
that you went through?
Just again, just thinking
about these three recordings,
or you know, these
three field recordings,
how did you find them?
>> Jaimeo Brown: Yes.
>> John Fenn: How many
did you have to listen to?
Were you looking
for certain stuff?
>> Jaimeo Brown: Yes.
>> John Fenn: Or did you kind of
go in with attention to texture?
>> Jaimeo Brown: Yeah,
great, great question.
Initially it was let me figure
out how to find anything.
>> John Fenn: Mm-hmm.
>> Jaimeo Brown: You know, just
because a lot of the material
of these early work songs
or these early spirituals,
they're very difficult to find.
I mean I happened to stumble
on a couple things online
that were more popular, and
then kind of through going
through the back ends and
figuring out licensing,
publishing, and I
eventually started,
happened to see a phone
number here or email here.
And them I'm calling
an email here and all
of a sudden it's eventually
leading me back to where,
ultimately where
the source of it is,
which is who owns the
actual material, which --
-- of course, Library
of Congress here,
just a lot of those
strains led me, led me here.
>> John Fenn: Mm-hmm.
>> Jaimeo Brown: And a lot
of times I'm listening
for maybe a theme --
>> John Fenn: Ok.
>> Jaimeo Brown: -- when
I'm composing or producing.
Maybe there's a theme
that I'm listening
to or maybe there is --
-- maybe there is a sound
that's connected to --
-- a certain concept that
has to do with the blues.
Within jazz, the blues
is just a huge root.
And so being able to figure out
where the blues actually came
from and to hear
how the blues --
-- how it came, came
about, you know.
You can't really get
that so much from a book.
You have to, there's
so much of a lineage
that comes just through,
through just sonically.
>> John Fenn: Mm-hmm.
>> Jaimeo Brown: And so I
was absorbing everything.
And a lot of times, a lot of my
decisions weren't necessarily --
-- oftentimes conceptually
or intellectually based.
They are more feeling
something and being moved
and then really using
that emotion
to create the forward momentum
of the composition or the idea.
And so, you know, I'm just also
really glad to be able to be
in a position to help bring more
of that out into the forefront
because it was very
difficult, once again,
for me to discover
a lot of this.
And so if I can help
show where --
-- where it comes from
or where it's located
and to show the power and
strength of it, you know,
that's another goal of what
I'm doing, Transcendance.
>> John Fenn: Great.
>> Jaimeo Brown: Yeah.
>> John Fenn: Well, thank
you, and I hope to see you
in the reading room again soon.
>> Jaimeo Brown: Yeah!
Thank you so much!
>> John Fenn: All right.
[ Laughter ]